the magic thing was a sense of
empowerment this idea of being able to
do things that other people couldn't do
or that appeared to be impressive it it
it was a a feeling of of power that's
what I was looking for because I felt so
completely not empowered in fact I felt
um enfeebled in many ways you think you
had a rough childhood no I don't
actually I think I had a lovely
childhood my parents adored me um I had
a very small circle of friends that that
I didn't realize at the time were
friends because they would sometimes
participate in the taunting as well but
I had some friends I did fine in school
and then um we moved from one town in
New Jersey to another town when I was 12
years old and from that point on that's
when I got picked up by the theater kids
I had never performed and the first kids
that came around and said hey new kid do
you sing I oh yeah well I read that you
were pursuing magic you went to an
actual mag I went to tanon Magic magic
Camp what is that magic Camp it you know
Camp is a euphemism it it's tannin is
still although it's diminished somewhat
they were the number one magic store in
our country and they were on Broadway at
like uh 48th Street in one of the great
so it's a chain of magic stores it
wasn't a chain it was a single it was a
world famous single single owner magic
store that professionals would come to
amateur still it does it's moved and
it's much smaller um but they used to
run a summer program which they called
the camp and they would they would have
in any two week session 20 to 30 kids
and they'd have magicians come in and
and if you wanted to be a close-up
magician they had a close-up guy if you
wanted to do things like the Box
Illusions or you know they would they
would uh Mentor you and I went and I
wanted I can't imagine sending a kid to
Camp get saw in half is is that what you
thought you were going to be doing for a
living yeah I wanted to be 12 but I
wanted to be well I started that when
when I was six I started doing I was
serious I would be in my little room
with my books and my my kits and my
little props that I got at you know
Ton's magic store um working on things
but I wanted to be a close-up magician I
wanted to do I wanted the magic to be in
my hands cuz even I as a kid I went if
there's a box the trick is the box it's
not the guy it's the Box okay so I
wanted to be the guy and what what
happened at tannin honestly is I started
to work with the guy on some basic card
manipulation and my hands to this day
are so small that a standard playing
card if I go to pomet some corner will
stick out somewhere I I do not have a
big enough hand to effectively and
easily Palm a standard even now as an
adult or manipulate yeah so and you know
if you take cards out of the equation as
as a close-up magician you you you've
diminished your repertoire quite a bit
though I know that you've gone to the
the magic I am an awardwinning magician
at the Magic Castle but I did not do a
close-up act I did a uh the the ACT I
did was based on mentalism tricks and I
presented them in a very different way
and I actually got the award more for
the uniqueness of how I presented these
things can you do a mental trick for us
now I know you're could I yeah like show
me
it if it's mentalism key word is Trick
it's a trick that I bring s there props
for it no almost every Mentalist I know
a couple that do some things that don't
don't don't ruin it for me but almost
almost you know magic is Magic it's a
trick if they're not saying hey I'm
psychic here's how you know if a
mentalist is a mentalist some magicians
judge on a on a say it's a trick they
they will not say that it's a trick I
know well that's a problem for you're
going to give away this behind the
scenes No but if you're if you're a
mentalist I should be able to go okay
I'm thinking of a color or I'm thinking
of a number I'll tell you what I I'll
make it easy a number between one and
five and they should have no problem
going oh I I know exactly what it is
that's that's a legitimate mind
reader